a few weeks ago i discussed a
fascinating new confirmation of albert
einstein's famous e equals mc squared
formula wherein physicists collided two
very heavy gold nuclei together and out
popped electron positron pairs not from
fusion or fission of the nuclei the gold
nuclei but instead from the photon cloud
that surrounds these charged particles
and today i'm going to tell you about an
ancillary benefit as long as we're
smashing particles into one another and
maybe engaging in some near misses
perhaps we can investigate some other
phenomena phenomena that's equally
exciting and this is called
birefringence stay tuned for another
fascinating episode of into the
impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so back at rick scientists were busy
smashing together these gold nuclei and
seeing what popped out but what's very
interesting to note is that anytime you
have a charged particle anytime you have
an ion for example it has an
electromagnetic field that surrounds it
that electromagnetic field for a
stationary particle will be radially
directed away from it charges in motion
produce a current and currents via
ampere's law produce magnetic fields so
you have an electromagnetic field when a
particle is in motion especially when
they're moving relativistically we call
these potentials advanced and [ __ ]
potentials and they lead to
electromagnetic radiation at the
boundary where these particles are
traversing through space at near
relativistic speeds obviously they do
that at rick the relativistic heavy ion
collider now radiation electromagnetic
waves are polarized in general and in
fact the polarization of the
electromagnetic waves can lead to very
interesting phenomena especially when
they pass through what are called
dielectrics pieces of glass crystals etc
etc and in fact we utilize those
properties of photons in many many
varieties in fact quite
likely the computer screen that you're
watching this very video on is making
use of the polarized effect of
electromagnetic waves
now we can also modify the polarization
through a variety of different means one
such mean is called birefringence when
you have a photon passing through a
linearly polarized photon or it could be
circularly polarized passing through a
medium it can its polarization direction
can rotate depending on the properties
of the crystal of the glass of the
material that it's propagating through
what wasn't known until very recently is
that this could occur in vacuum as well
so what is birefringence birefringence
is this passage of light that gets
afflicted and affected depending on the
polarization of that light passing
through the material here's a piece a
chunk of what's called calcite or
icelandic spar i'll have an inset from
other work that i look at i show you
from the laboratory here so
birefringence is a strange property
acting like it has two indices of
refraction you'd have very tough time
seeing if your glasses were made of this
type of material this is a type of
calcite i've written just the words
birefringence on this post-it note and
you can see when i put the crystal on
top you get two copies of the
words and that's just because the paths
of each of the polarized light which is
coming from an unpolarized
image which is just the words
birefringence such as ink reflecting
light in different colors but it's
unpolarized so there's half polarized
vertically half polarized horizontally
and as it traverses this crystal it will
appear to the eye as if the light coming
out came from two different directions
slightly offset the amount of offset
depends on a crystal parameter the
birefringent coefficient
of the
of the crystal and also how thick the
crystal is this is a pretty thick
crystal which i got uh from uh from
superman's home
planet
uh and if you then suppress one of the
two polarizations one of these linear
polarizers you get
an image that's 100 horizontally
polarized or vertically polarized
depending on the rotation of this axis
and you can actually mix it up and so
the light being unpolarized has equal
amounts of horizontal and vertical
polarization so when it goes through one
of these it gets filtered you reject one
of those depending on what axis
how the axis is oriented as i rotate
this disk and you can actually suppress
all the light if you have a second
polarizer as i do here you can suppress
all of it you can transmit half of it
etc etc so this is very cool phenomenon
now the question is does the cosmos
appear in this exact same way that's a
topic we're going to explore on today's
video this effect was first discovered
way back in 1669 even older than me and
i can tell you that this has been a
phenomenon that's fascinated me since i
learned about it
birefringence literally means double
refraction it was first accounted for by
a danish scientist who had a very cool
name rasmus bartholin and this took
place in 1669 and really perplexed him
and many scientists for almost 150 years
so when light travels through a medium
like glass plastic your lenses or even
this calcite hunk of calcite here it
gets slowed down and actually it can get
slowed down by an amount known as the
refractive index which is related to the
properties in the microscale of these of
the composition of the atoms in the
crystal now you take the speed of light
in vacuum which is defined to be uh 300
000 kilometers per second
approximately you divide that by the
index of refraction in the case of
calcite it's about 1.3 so the speed of
light slows down appreciably 33 or more
so in water which is another dielectric
material which is translucent
transparent depending on its state
the speed of light decreases from 300
000 kilometers per second to just about
33 percent less than that uh so closer
to 200 000 kilometers per second owing
to the effect of the slowing through the
atomic lattice or through the
water molecules in this case by about 33
that's the index of a fraction of water
now in some materials like calcite you
not only get one index of refraction you
actually get two indices of refraction
and the indices depend on whether the
light is vertically polarized or
horizontally polarized and there are
other materials that can do so for
circular polarization so called left and
right handed circular polarization
that is the phenomenon known as
birefringence in calcite icelandic spar
the question is where does this arise
from
well it comes down to the atomic
properties of the calcite in this case
it has a crystalline structure that's
not cubic it's not random and it
actually will slow down or
relatively slow down one of the rays of
light as it passes through depending on
whether or not it's polarized vertically
or horizontally now what does
polarization mean well light waves
are so-called transverse electromagnetic
waves that means their field the forcing
functions that they have electric
electric field and magnetic field are
transverse to the direction
perpendicular to the direction of
propagation they're also mutually
perpendicular in that if the light ray
is going towards you as my index finger
is the electromagnetic field shown in
the uh in the upper
thumb here that will indicate a
perpendicular relationship between the
direction of motion but also the
magnetic field will be perpendicular to
that and they'll both oscillate at a
frequency corresponding to the frequency
of the light that is being propagated
so that's what's called a transverse
wave the force which is defined as the
direction of the electromagnetic field
that's the polarization the electric
field defines the polarization the
magnetic field is 90 degrees to that and
to the direction of motion that that
completely constrains the three vectors
of propagation
and of electromagnetic
forces and fields so it's different from
a water wave or from a slinky or
something like that
so because light is transverse you can
get two different indices of refraction
depending on the polarization of the
light
now amorphous materials like glass or
even liquids like water have relatively
random or behavior as light goes through
it so there's no need for the electric
field to get more affected or slowed
down slowed down by an effective index
of refraction that's greater than for
the magnetic field component
so they don't experience that in water
and glass and amorphous materials and
even in like regular crystal cubic
structures as well
like salt or something like that you
don't get a slowdown in the index of
refraction that differs from the
vertical and the horizontal i.e from the
electric and magnetic components
but for things like calcite this
icelandic spar material again we have
known for hundreds of years that this
would actually take place so it would
travel at different speeds and calcite
it depending on if the light is
polarized vertically or horizontally
the idea that light could be composed of
a transverse wave like phenomenon was
first proposed by thomas young a famous
uh young's double slit fame and then it
was only proven uh slightly later than
that by fresnel spelled fresnel and we
uh we know now that light is a
transverse electromagnetic wave
that means it can experience this double
refraction this type of strange behavior
so the crystal structure in combination
with the transverse nature of
electromagnetic waves is responsible for
the property that light can be refracted
differently depending on its
polarization and this only occurs in
certain media or so scientists thought
until very recently when our friends at
their star experiment at rick the
relativistic heavy ion collider decided
hmm i wonder if this effect could take
place in vacuum with no crystal no
medium and that would be as if the
vacuum of space in the inside of their
particle accelerator as if it was
depending like a crystal it was behaving
and that would be like the interior of
the rick star experiment was behaving as
if it were actually filled with a
dielectric material that was not only
possessing an index of refraction but it
had an index of refraction which
differed depending on the polarization
of light in some ways the effect was
perhaps no better tested
than at rick and in fact this is a
consequence of the breit wigner study
that we talked about a few weeks ago in
our video let there be matter so let's
go back to the star chamber at rick
let's see if with strong enough
electromagnetic fields present as there
were when these relativistic ions are
coming close and colliding to one
another can we produce large enough
magnetic fields to actually polarize the
vacuum and make it depend and have a
different propensity for the
polarization states of vertical light
and horizontal light to emerge from
these particle
collisions let's go and investigate what
they found
so i'm going to go back and talk about
refraction what is refraction well light
always wants to take the shortest
optical path it wants to minimize the
action the so-called action it wants to
spend the least amount of time getting
from point a to point b and if that
means it has to go through a medium at a
specific angle that angle is determined
by the snell index of refraction law as
shown on screen
now when it changes its path it will
still reach its destination and it will
do so by bending and taking exactly the
path that minimizes the action or the
distance or the time really the
principle of least time to get to its
destination and that is what refraction
is the index of refraction categorizes
and characterizes how much the light
slows down and bends you can think about
light as a series of wavefronts and when
it enters a new medium if it enters at
an angle to that medium it will change
its direction depending on the relative
difference between the index of
refraction of the medium that it's now
traversing and the previous medium that
it was in usually assumed to be vacuum
now in a crystal you can get two
different indices of refraction
depending on the crystal structure as
long as it's not a cubic crystal because
the cube looks the same uh fro no matter
which angle is coming in as long as the
the light beam the direction which the
light is traveling uh is normal to the
face of the crystal and you can always
rotate the crystal so that it the face
that the light is impinging upon is
perpendicular to the light direct travel
direction and therefore perpendicular to
both the electric field which is
defining the polarization state by
convention and the magnetic field at
right angles to both those vectors
and so because the index of refraction
changes with the polarization of
incoming light in birefringent materials
so too does the amount by which the
light refracts for these two different
polarization states this is called
birefringence you can also get another
example that's sort of allied called
faraday rotation or the faraday effect
or circular birefringence and that's
usually obtained when you have a
magnetic field present that's energizing
a plasma for example and that can create
a rotation of the plane of polarization
as well in fact we're going to plan to
use the simon's observatory and other
experiments to look for the earliest
magnetic fields in the universe by using
this faraday rotation effect for
polarization calibration i'll go on the
top
of the instrument to calibrate the think
cmvb mode signals that we're hoping to
see
when an electromagnetic wave say light
is impinging upon a medium which through
which we've suffused a magnetic field
the rotation of the plane of
polarization will change depending on
the strength of the magnetic field and
the properties of the medium in which
it's traversing it will rotate that's
called faraday rotation now in the rick
experiment you can also see a
circumstance where the magnetic field
interacting with a photon could also
take place thus providing an opportunity
for the circular birefringence
phenomenon to be exhibited so the
photons that come together engaging in
these collisions are linearly polarized
this is exactly the same type of
polarization property that we explored
we talked about birefringence in
crystals like calcite earlier
now because these photons come together
over such a brief amount of time these
collisions are occurring at relativistic
velocities for both of the nuclei that
are coming together
so you'll get a random orientation of
the photon polarities and then you can
measure the outgoing distribution of
their polarization states and you can
compare is the outcome also on average
is it unpolarized equal amounts of
horizontal and vertical polarization and
that's what the researchers investigated
so vacuum birefringence would say that
in a vacuum in a strong magnetic field
applied to it photons can emerge and
they can be differentially rotated they
can have a difference in angle behaving
as they emerge at different angles they
can emerge differently just as if the
vacuum now this is in a chamber that's
completely evacuated in a laboratory
pumped out there's no crystals in there
there's nothing in there so you're
seeing
uh you're seeing a double index of
refraction birefringence in vacuum
thanks to the magnetic field polarizing
the vacuum this is a fascinating
phenomenon and the index of refraction
will differ depending on the
polarization of the and the distribution
of the light that's emerging from these
interactions
so it looks like a birefringent medium
it acts like a birefringent medium and
therefore it's quacking just like a
birefringent medium so it's plausible to
say that a polarized vacuum strongly
polarized to the magnetic field behaves
almost as if it's a crystal except it's
a vacuum so it's almost as if we have
polarized
that's exactly what researchers have
claimed to discover at rick now it's
interesting to note that the scientists
who initially described this process and
started talking about this photon photon
reaction producing the particle
antiparticle electron and positron pairs
brighton wheeler never thought this
process would be detectable
so i'm showing here from a slide talk
given at cern
this shows the classification of various
fundamental interactions between light
and matter and you can see one of them
shown uh in the lower side on the lower
right is the bright wheeler process
where we have this exchange of two
of two photons coming in and out go an
electron positron pair and again this
phenomenon can be classified and also
seen as an allied phenomenon to this
vacuum polarization phenomenon
so here we see a description of vacuum
magnetic birefringence with a term
that's unimaginably
small and was thought never to be
observable and in fact may never be
observable so we can discuss
birefringence vacuum birefringence now
birefringence can take place at the
quantum electrodynamic level so
birefringence of the qed vacuum is shown
here we see great detail shown here the
geometry of what takes place in the star
experiment and you have a what's called
a probe photon which is called probe
gamma and an outcoming gamma that comes
out the observed gamma and they're
rotated by some angle that's the
birefringence that's a rotation angle
due to the polarization of the vacuum by
the applied magnetic field so by
measuring the tiny differences between
the polarized angle that emerges from
the input polarization angle
and comparing with this theoretical
prediction of the type of modulation
that should take place the researchers
reported the first earth-based
observations at a very high seven almost
seven sigma statistical significance
level of vacuum birefringence it shows
that nature is very strange and the
universe may not be exactly the way that
we conceived it that we can measure such
minute effects in total contrast to what
bright and wheeler predicted as shown
here in our 1930s paper now we're
measuring these things almost 100 years
later the creativity the cleverness of
these experimental physicists is quite
unimaginable and we can only imagine
where we can go next that the universe
itself could possess a type of
birefringence that the universe could
act as if it is a giant crystal
obviously there's no crystal there's no
ether there's no spheres sorry aristotle
but instead the universe could manifest
a tiny little divergence from perfect
symmetry for vertical and horizontal
polarized light and in so doing could
behave as if the universe is uh
birefringent and that could have
ramifications not only for our
understanding of electromagnetism but
for understanding of what is known as
lorentz and variance violation
a topic i talked about was sean carroll
in 2020 when there was a tentative claim
made only about the 2.3 2.4 sigma
statistical significance level far far
lower than the rick experiment is
claiming and this by researchers miami
and komatsu is still being investigated
and it's something that we hope to
follow up with projects like the simon's
array and the simon's observatory this
instrument we hope will take us back to
the beginning of time
perhaps so stay tuned maybe the universe
will be found to have a twist to it the
universe has been twisted in the past
and there's no reason not to think that
our best limits on so-called cosmic
birefringence birefringence of the
vacuum of einstein of interstellar space
could also be possessed this behavior
and that would turn physics on its head
because the underpinning of all of
modern physics is predicated on symmetry
known as lorentz invariants so violating
that would have huge ripples for quantum
mechanics for relativity and for our
understanding of what are called the
standard model of particles forces and
fields and our standard model of
cosmology so stay tuned for upcoming
experiments and results from projects
like the simon's array the simon's
observatory the bicep array and other
projects studying the largest laboratory
in the universe which is the universe
for now i'm brian keating chancellor
distinguished professor of physics and
co-director of the arthur c clark center
for human imagination thanking you for
going into the impossible
if you want to learn more about lorentz
and variance violation watch this video
with me and sean carroll otherwise click
here and see conversations with nine
nobel prize winners and more on my think
like a nobel prize winner playlist
[Music]